- On this episode, we just
rocked out episode 182.
(bumping hip hop)
♫ You ask questions and I answer them.
♫ This is the #AskGaryVee Show. ♫
Everybody it's
Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 182
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
We're on a little bit of a roll,
is this three actual
bushiness days in a row?
Thursday, Friday, Monday.
There's a lot of people off on
this President's day Monday,
not VaynerMedia, I'm sure
they're super pumped about that
but like it's weird I don't
think this should be a day off.
I like President's and everything,
but I don't know it's
something I've never taken off,
and I do say everything
stems from the top, so.
We've started adding more and
more official vacation days
here at Vayner as we've grown up,
it used to only be like Christmas.
(laughing)
You better be in January 1st.
Alright India it's good to see you.
I'm in an interesting mellow serious mode,
I'm very in a serious mode.
Are you ok?
- [India] My food's here
and I have to pay for it.
- Alright go ahead, go ahead.
Well actually you should
ask the first question.
She'll be right there.
- First question from Chris,
- [Voiceover] Christopher R asks,
"Gary, have you ever dropped the ball
"on making a decision
due to over thinking it?"
- Chris I would say that my...
I almost need her to repeat
it, but I think I got it.
Actually I sent it to her so I got it.
I got it.
The reason I sent it to India,
was I say this Chris in the feed,
is I'm actually normally making mistakes
in the other direction.
So I tend not to overthink
at all, I'm very intuitive,
and most of my business mistakes
have been to act too quickly
and then have to bail out.
I have found that speed trumps everything,
and so for me when I
weigh opportunity costs,
I'd rather start something
both money and time if
I intuitively feel it
and then let it fail six
months or a year later.
New concepts I have for
Vayner, new divisions,
new types of wine's for Wine Library,
things I've done for my own brand
and I wanna push so many of you for this
I really wanna push a lot of you.
So many of you are not taking action
because you overthink it, you
overthink it, you overthink it
I always say deploy your resources
that you can afford to lose.
A lot of you don't have the dollars,
I used to not have the dollars,
but I had my time.
The reason I punted at my twenties
is because I didn't have money,
or I didn't have a lot of it.
You know a lot of you
hear about the three
million dollar business,
I love when people try to rag on me
and say oh if everybody had a
three million dollar business
I mean every single kid
that gets 500,000 dollars in startup
which was millions have more
dollar resources than I had.
We didn't have dollars,
the business did three million dollars,
it made 300,000 dollars in profit
in selling three million
dollars worth of liqour
and then it still had to pay expenses.
My dad took home his salary,
like we had no money.
But I had my time,
and I would test things,
and I stayed up.
I didn't punt my twenties
for kicks and giggles,
I pumped them because the only
resource I had was my time,
and so I had to work 18 hours a day
because that's what I had.
Got it?
So taking action, especially
if it doesn't cost you money
and it's just time is
always a better answer
than pondering or thinking
or trying to decide if this is gonna work,
you don't know.
The learning of the failure
is as equal to the victory of it.
The thing's I've learned in my 20 years,
the reason I'm so advanced
as a business person
in my own mind is not
only have I worked a lot,
but this work hard work
smart thing I've worked smart
and one of the smartest things I do
as an entrepreneur and a business person
is I do things so I can understand
whether they work or not.
You can't just sit here and say
"Is this going to work or not?"
Debate it your whole life, never do it,
and then not know the answer.
Like no.
One of two great things happen,
one you did it and it worked
and you made money and you won
and you got accolades and it worked
Wine Library TV, it worked.
The classes I was gonna do,
I'm trying to think of things that failed
another thing is that I
just forget them so quickly.
I'll work on this, you know India
I wanna do top 11 things
I did on Wine Library that didn't work.
Local van delivery,
at scale I never did.
So one of two things happen,
either it works and you make money
the email service it worked,
or it doesn't and you're like
well I'm not gonna do that again.
This whole indecisiveness
when you can do it,
if you don't have the
money you can't do it
so what the fuck are you
thinking about it for?
"You know I wonder if I buy
a building in New York City
will it go up in value? I wonder."
The answer is it's gonna work,
but guess what I don't have
400 million dollars liqiud
to buy the fucking Empire State Building,
type of building because
you can't even buy
that for 400 million.
This is an interesting question,
the answer is no,
I've never failed because
of indecisiveness.
I've only failed because I've done stuff,
but I'd argue that I didn't
really fail I learned,
I might have micro failed but I macro won.
- [Voiceover] J Scot asks,
"Gary do you expect your own
employees to work like you do?
"Does it affect your opinion of them?"
- J, I do not expect any of my employees
to work as hard as I do
because it's not their business,
and I get so mad at so many of you
that get mad at employees
that don't work as hard
as you, they shouldn't.
Why in the world would they?
Now there's plenty of employees here
that know that I value
hard work and hustle,
and they know they'll be
rewarded within the context,
but no I do not expect
anybody to work harder than me
and I think one of the quickest
ways for a business to fail
is to have an employee
working harder than you
and let me break that down.
So many of you think you make it,
and then you get to chill.
Then what?
You expect everybody underneath
you to work hard to sustain.
Nobody cares that you worked
your ass off for 15 years,
to get to this point
if you're fucking sailing
right now and fishing
and like hanging out with
your boyfriend on the beach
for a month and you're
supposed to hold it up?
Why because they worked hard
for 15 years, what about them?
People have their own best at interests,
and if you're not out working them.
As a matter of fact never,
I have to work so hard to
create an infastructure
that can even allow me
to have the audacity
to have people to wanna work
with me for a long time.
The only way I can even expect
all of them to work with me
for a long time like I want them to
is that I create such a big thing
that they can make the monies
and have the challenges
both get the monetary values they want
the work life balance and the
money they wanna take home
and do things that are
interesting and creative
and challenging and not the same thing.
The only way I can do that
is to build the biggest thing possible
which means I have to outwork them
to have the wants and needs
and audacity to have
people to work for me,
talented people to work for me
people that can really move the needle.
So no it doesn't change my opinion
as a matter of fact I hope,
and I know a lot of you are
watching right now at Vayner.
I hope that I'm creating
something that allows
hundreds of them to have a nine to six,
not nine to five,
a nine to six 45 hour
to 50 hour kind of job
that pays them enough to be happy
and gives them plenty of hours
to be on the bowling team,
or knit, or work on
their music on the side,
or come home for dinner every night.
No I do not judge them,
because if they wanted
to be exactly like me,
or if they were wired like me,
or had the ambition like me,
or the talent like me,
they'd be doing it for themselves.
As they should, and I want that for them.
Yeah I'm in a good zone.
Yoesef or Joesef?
- Hi Gary here's Josef,
recently you were complaining that
you are not receiving
enough questions from us
so here is one from the heart of Europe
in the city of Prague
my question is about recruitment.
LinkedIn is currently
standard for recruitment,
how do you recruit your people,
and is LinkedIn a crucial
part of this process?
- Josef thank you for the question,
and by the way that just excited me
more video questions
with awesome backgrounds
from all over different places
something that's signature
like if you live near Mount Rushmore
I would love one of those.
Anybody near Mount Rushmore I'll take it.
Are you getting ready
for your summer vacation
as you get around,
more visually exciting
things for #AskGaryVee
you will get on the show.
We use LinkedIn hard
we even pay for the program
it's a great utility it
works great for Vayner,
but nothing works harder than the brand.
When you build something that's special
people are coming to you
instead of you recruiting.
The greatest way to
recruit is to not recruit,
it's to do something
that is so significant,
or interesting, or
curious, or challenging,
that people want to work for you.
Vayner's now starting to get that momentum
even though I don't promote it,
this is me holding off promotion
if you're wondering.
Even though I don't promote it
what we are doing is we're
trying to let the word of mouth
or the people that get
through all the traps
I put out to get through
and see what's actually going on here.
So I would say LinkedIn
is a great tool for us,
we love it, we use it, we use it a lot,
but the word of mouth of
the internal employees
telling other people they
should come and work here.
"Oh my God this is an amazing place."
and people that are sniffing
out and talking to other people
clients are human beings,
my clients are human beings,
meaning when they know
they're getting great work
and they're out to dinner with a buddy
who happened to work at an
agency that's a competitior
and they're like
"You know who you should
really look at? Vayner."
Do you know how many
employees we get that way?
Word of mouth.
So the two ways to do it is,
to do great stuff that
everybody wants to work for you,
and I do think the utility
of LinkedIn is great.
I think Twitter search
is incredible as well.
I got a surprise for you guys.
Paul let's go.
I like this part.
So tall.
- Good to see you again.
Way too tall.
- No, I love it, not way too tall.
I love it, sit.
Alright Vayner Nation,
this is a lot of fun
for a lot of you that have
been following this story.
This is an incredibly interesting moment
for many of them, a lot of them,
that haven't...
- For me as well
- Well, thank you.
For many of them who
have not heard the story,
I'll give you a minute
to give the background
of how you're sitting here right now.
- My name is Paul Jonas
many of you know me already from
being the hitchhiker guy from
Vancouver to New York City,
I traveled without money just hitchhiked
all the way to New York
City to get on the show,
which I am right now.
- So what made you announce to,
on what social platform
and where did you announce
"I am in Vancouver and I am
going to hitchhike to New York,
with no money to be on
the #AskGaryVee Show."
- It started on Facebook,
and then it went to
instagram, and Twitter.
Where both got quite a bit of a fan base
and got a lot of support.
- And what day did you
start this journey?
- On the 3rd of January.
- January 3rd
- Right
- And what was going on, on January 2nd?
Through your mind?
- January 2nd I was meditating,
in a meditation camp,
- Interesting glad I aked
- And I was not doing anything,
I was just
- Chilling
- Right,
and the next day I started the trip,
and it was very exciting.
- And how long have you
been watching the show?
- I'd say around a year,
but not like every episode,
I'd say in this month I was traveling
then I was very much into it
so I was getting more into it.
- So what happened, you
started in Vancouver
and the game plan was
I'm gonna get to New York
on the back of peoples kindness
is how I saw it from afar.
- Right I didn't spend any money
so it was completely on
the kindness of strangers,
and I didn't ask anyone
for food on the whole trip
it was always from them.
So I would tell them about
the trip I was going to do,
and they would be like
hey let me help you out,
let me give you some food.
- So before we get to you asking
me a question for the show,
what about...
I'm working on my interview skills.
What about what was the strangest
and funniest thing that
happened on the trip?
- I'd say the strangest
thing was meeting a guy
who was in prison for
attempted murder for 16 years
and I was in his...
- Wait hold on
- I was in his car, and then he told me,
so I was in there already.
- Hold on let's take a step back,
you get into a strangers car
- Right.
- and you're telling me
you're in this mans car
and you're just shooting the shit
and he say's oh yeah I
was in prison for 16 years
on attempted murder.
- What I asked is I was
like "What are you up to?"
and he's like "I just came out
of prison, attempted murder"
I'm like that's not good, that's not good.
(laughing)
- Were you scared?
Yes and no.
- A little bit and you know the thing is
I was sitting in the back seat
and he had these like tools
and I'm like this is not good.
But he was a good guy,
he was a good good guy.
- And what about the funniest?
- Hmm.
- Or some other anecdote, like
anybody really interesting
or did you do anything fun,
did anybody cook you
like a seven course meal?
- I was eating so much good food,
I was invited for lamb steak,
Thai food, Vietnamese food,
I was eating better than I usually do.
New York City is bad for me.
- It is?
- Like food wise, before
I was not spending money.
- Got it, totally.
So we met, some of you saw our interaction
for the first time on
DailyVee a couple episodes ago,
when we were walking
it didn't make footage.
You told me a little bit
about your background,
you're an entrepreneur in Germany
- Right.
I started up an entrepreneur
early, like five or six
and selling flowers just like I told you.
After 13 corporate jobs, I told myself
I'm never going to work for anyone else
but with someone else
and now I've got my own company
a furniture company and we sell furniture.
- So how much longer are
you staying in the States?
- Just two more weeks
- Then back?
- Back to Germany, back
on the clock and working.
- Good trip?
- Very good trip.
- What is your question?
- Before my question I just want to say
thank you to everyone who helped me.
- You wanna give out some names?
A couple shout outs?
- What I really want to do is
I actually want to give back,
and I want to support you as well.
I'm gonna buy eight of these books,
I'm going to give two away
to Kenmark and Jesse Mercells
who supported me of the Vayner Nation,
and six I will give away
to everyone who is sharing this video
I will pick six and give them a copy.
- Very nice, now what happens
if I pull your name from the
receipt pool on the 23rd?
You gonna give that away?
- I thought about giving
it away to anyone,
but I would give it away to my
business partner in Germany.
- Much respect, very good.
I guess in London then,
that's a quicker trip.
- Whatever makes sense.
- So what's the question?
- Over the last months,
I realized myself I'm
consuming way too much content,
whether it's yours or
Ferris, Flint or whoever
and I have way too much to execute on
so I decided not to ask a
typical #AskGaryVee question
because it would be consuming again
and instead go with the most
practical one I could think of
which is are you interested
in having me as in intern
for a period of one month
in one year from now
and to make it harder for me
and more interesting for you
only if by then I have
executed on the advice
you've given me on DailyVee
to publish a book about this trip?
- Done.
(laughing)
If you didn't follow that,
because it's a good
accent but I can hear it
I don't know how good your audio is.
You're going to come back and intern
at Vayner Media for a month
but only if you publish a
book on what I told you.
This also didn't make the screen,
I'm like look you need to write a book.
- It make the screen.
- Oh it did make the screen,
I don't watch my own stuff.
Though I do watch 14
DRock you crushed that.
Yes 100 percent.
- Cool
- Alright brother, thanks for stopping by.
I will say bye after
I'm done with the show.
Alright that was fun, super cool right?
This was a good episode
you're right, India.
He did a great job, he set
out and made it happen.
Kind of cool.
Let's move on.
- [India] Two more questions?
- Yeah let's do two more.
Since he didn't ask a question.
Statement Gary Vee,
hashtag Statement Gary Vee.
Actually he was growth hacking,
he was trying to make his shit happen,
I respect the hussle.
Let's go.
- [Voiceover] Tammie asks,
"Gary what brings you peace?
"There is such fun in the hustle sure,
"but what brings the calm and ease for you?"
- That's a very interesting question,
nice pick there, India.
You know what, I think that I'm very basic
I really want the people I
care about to be healthy.
You know what's really sad for me?
I'll share, and this is gonna get
into being one of the deeper episodes,
I think you guys are going
to be really surprised
by how I act when something
bad happens in my life.
I really don't care about
all this, like really don't.
Like way, way more than you think.
Like my ability to not give a fuck
about not buying the New York Jets
is so much greater than you think,
I think that when I completely disappear
for nine weeks or a year or whatever it is
this moment will get
clipped and shared a lot.
Hopefully in 50 years, but
whenever that time comes,
when the first tragic illness
and or death in my family
happens you will not see me.
Listen the truth is
I've never dealt with it
maybe I'd rely on you even more,
maybe I'd be on more than ever
because it's my outlet.
I can tell you one thing,
you know I don't care about
book sales, or wine sales,
on VaynerMedia clients.
So what gives me peace is I know who I am,
I really know who I am.
That's what really give me peace, India,
I'm really in tuned to who I am.
My self awareness is way off the charts.
Like I just know who I
am, I know how I roll,
I know what I care about,
I know that I care.
I had a fan tell another fan like
"I don't watch Gary Vee anymore,
he's just imposing his hustle.
Like all he wants to impose is
that he outworks all of us."
Like it bothers me
that I'm not doing a
good enough job balancing
that, that person
believes that to be true.
I know exactly what I'm doing,
I also know that the tweet
where he made fun of me,
the next tweet he did a Snapchat post
with the five steps of how
to follow him on snapchat
which is a complete replica
of the way I did it.
That's called following tactical advice,
so you know, I know who
I am through and through.
So I'm at global peace always,
because I know who I am,
I know what my intent is and
I know I'm providing value
and I know that even when
I'm in book selling mode
when I'm asking and I'm
throwing right hooks
that I'm always providing more value
than I'm asking for in return.
Than I'm asking for.
I might be getting more value,
somebody may buy 500 books
and I may give them 400
books worth of value.
I'm never asking for more value in return
than I'm giving ever
and that gives me enormous peace.
I think I'm whole with everybody,
people that know me the best
know I'm most uncomfortable
if I'm not whole with them.
I spent my whole fucking 20s
getting whole with my parents.
Thanks.
(inaudible talking)
nope
Adaeze, a daisy or Adaeze.
Got it.
I though a Daisy actually made the show.
I was like sorry Mother
Nature I do love you.
Daisies are talking to me this is weird.
- This guy asked you a question.
- Yes.
- Hey Gary how you
doing, my name is Adaeze
and I'm a producer song
writer artist from Barbados
I've been asking this question
and I'm gonna keep asking
if you're an artist manager
what's something you
would have your artist do
that artists right now aren't leveraging?
So something completely
different, out of the box.
Thanks a lot.
Adaeze, first of all you are cool as shit.
I would probably be focusing on Musically,
I'm fascinated by Musically.
It's a social network that's emerging
it's around music
and I think that if you're an artist
and you're doing creative
on top of your own music
and then reaching out to other people.
So let me break this down very tactically
because it can lead to
what musicians should
be doing on Musically
article that I would love to get out there
because I think Musically
is absolutely
at least already in Yik Yak territory
where it's like really got my attention.
Musically is an app that
reminds me of like DubSmash
where a lot of people do lip syncing
but you can also do Vine
and Instagram behind music
because they figured out the music rights
or I don't know how it's actually working
but I know these days
you couldn't get them up.
They're probably under terms and services
of how much you can sample blah blah blah.
Anyway if I was a musician,
I would try to put out content
on top of my own music,
that may not pop because your music
is not as popular as all the other music
but what I would do is
start reaching out to other
influences in that community.
One of the best ways
to reach out to people
in a community is to become
a part of the community.
You can't go on Reditt and spam everybody,
but if you actually read
and engaged and commented
and shared and were a part
of Reditt for two years
you've got permission to
throw your right hook.
I would become a major,
major part of Musically.
I would use my own
music to create content,
I would use other peoples
I would comment on the
top 100 peoples content,
engage, join.
Even in Barbados,
I would literally take all my money
and fly to New York or
L.A. Musically meet up
become part of the new community
and then you've got
permission to do things.
So for me, that's what I would do.
I would absolutely become part
of the Musically community,
engage, comment, share, create,
and then do real life things.
Engage with them in other networks,
comment on their Instagrams,
don't spam them, don't creep them,
just become part of it
and then I really think you
have a chance of popping out
because if you think about it
imagine if you were doing
this with Vine early on
and you got the 40 biggest Viners
to do something with your music
and meme it you could really hit it,
and then if you're a musician
you could actually write a hook
that's around Musically culture
like that 15 second flip.
Jesus that was weird.
You know you could integrate
something that's unique
about Musically in a song
that then people could use.
Holding it down like Snapchat.
You know like that kind of stuff.
Back when Snapchat you
had to hold it down?
You see where I'm going.
That was a good show.
That was a really, really rock solid show.
(inaudible talking)
Yeah question of the day,
how many books are you gonna buy?
(laughing)
That's literally what I want to know.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(bumping hip hop)